thank you very much for crystals for the
wonderful introduction and for all of
you for showing up and i hope i will
have something somewhat interesting to
offer too many of you that are more
afraid that many of you actually know
some of the things i have to say i guess
i want to add one more sink to
Christophsis introduction i was here on
so bad
I'm so sorry to take the introduction
I'm so sorry I want to add one more see
toothpicks introduction is that I was
heroes a stick said I was here as a
postdoc in as one of my first post Docs
and the first encounter is with the US
but I almost also was here at 99 2000
and in fact it was the influence of
Berkeley interactions and interacting
with crystals that got me interested in
game theory and in fact timbers here is
a graduate student and I guess we have a
lot to thank to crystals and the
generally the Berkeley environment to
get us onto this interesting topic so is
there I do want to talk about learning
and efficiency in games and I guess
maybe efficiency will come in the second
part of the talk I want to start with
learning in games and I guess to get you
set I'm going to alternate between
thinking of games we're learning
behavior from the players is there a
reasonable assumption and I hope you
will agree the reasonable assumption and
thinking of very very simple games where
I can better illustrate of what exactly
happens if people are learning so I
guess the kind of games I want to think
of where I think learning is a
reasonable behavior I've seen any kind
of game that happens over and over again
and I guess traffic writing is
definitely one of them if you one of
those car owners and I don't know when a
picture of a second and you're driving
in that car chances are that this is
some sort of morning Russia traffic or
afternoon rush hour traffic and you're
doing this every day and in fact Yulia
you are learning you're trying to figure
out what is the best way to drive
between the two notions you wanna go
similar things happening on the internet
with packets though it isn't exactly the
package that I learning but instead the
routers but nonetheless in somebody the
same thing is happening someone is
trying to figure out gradually
what might be the right thing to do
another domain of this form is
advertisement or a certainly at search
advertisement or any sort of internet
advertisement where this model has been
studied or considered again if you're
selling or buying ads in some search
platform and I guess it's a little fuzzy
picture here of even though i think
yahoo ads on the picture then anyone any
particular ad here has very doesn't have
much value but yet this search
advertisement is what supports much of
the internet industry and the way it
doesn't that there's millions of
interactions here and as a result it's
not at all a one-time played game it's a
game where you bidding for advertisement
is that happens over and over again I
wanna model this as a repeated
interaction and I want to think of the
players objective function as trying to
minimize or maximize depends on what the
objective function is they want good
average performance they want to have
good performance most of the time this
is definitely a good model for for
selling advertisement or bind
advertisement so I guess I want to think
of games in which players interact over
and over again and in an environment and
I want to think of what should I expect
to happen in these kind of games now I
said I'm going to think of learning but
I didn't tell you what I meant by
learning and that was not an accident
because the first part of the talk I
want to think about what I could mean by
learning about what kind of models would
I mean by learning so I guess there are
multiple modes here of what one could
consider and maybe the simplest one is
to assume that since they're repeating
the same game we can
take the equilibrium of the you know
first pair time period assume they were
smart enough they figured out this
equilibrium and they repeat it over and
over again i'm going to call this the
Nash equilibrium of the one-shot game or
I could say that no no no that's not
what they doing they trying to influence
the behavior of the neighbors and I
should think of something complicated
how I'm going to you know aggressively
do something in step 1 so as to
intimidate the company so that in step
17 my life gets better that would be the
Nash equilibrium off or the equilibrium
of the repeater game instead of this I
want to say that they're engaging in a
simple learning activity and I'll come
to try to give you options of what might
mean by learning activity and also how
that relates to at some of those other
notions generally by the end of the talk
I want to think about what but what can
be so in the beginning of the talk i'm
going to just talk about what do I mean
by learning historically had games are
learning interact with each other over
in the beginning of this area but by the
second half of the talk I want to talk
about what can we say about outcomes of
games that is what happens in a game if
everyone is engaging in some sort of
learning and then hopefully if I have
enough time or a little bit at the end I
want to actually emphasize one
particular advantage of learning
compared to some of these other walls of
thinking about games that learners are
infamously are famously good to adjust
for changing environments if something
changes in your environment and you
write running a sort of learning
algorithm one would think learning is
good at this and certainly many forms of
learning are good at this and I guess I
want to think about others the game
theory version of learning think about
the fact that the environment might be
changing as you
playing the game remember this is a
repeated game if you thinking of traffic
patterns maybe things changed slowly in
that business like it could be you know
some very big company opens a lot of
people suddenly want to go there in the
morning or some Road closes and
therefore some other roads get more
congested so traffic patterns can change
and certainly in the advertising
internet advertisement business it's
even more prevalent something becomes
popular in a regular catcher and as a
result there's lots and lots of people
searching for certain words something
became less popular and less people are
searching the environments changing as
we speak all the time but this is going
to come back you might want to keep this
in mind as one of the advantages of
learning but we'll come back to this so
as I promised the first thing I want to
talk about is he's had it varied
learning come or how did learning relate
to games and what do I even mean by
learning and to do that I actually want
to go to the opposite end and rather
than seeking of traffic rotting and
advertisement which are really the
prototypical games that we playing over
and over again i'm going to use very
simplistic silly examples so here is
sort of the classical two-person games
that hopefully you've also seen this is
a simple coordination game in which and
this is maybe a standard game Siri
notation there are two players here as a
column player who is choosing between
sorry role player who's choosing between
these two rows and a column player who's
choosing between people these two
columns the strategies are called a and
B and they both would like to coordinate
that is play the same same strategy if
they don't coordinate they get a payoff
or utility of one each and if they miss
coordinate one of them chooses eight
element B then they get utility of zero
that's a game called the coordination
game the Nash equilibrium of the game is
Nash equilibrium is any stable strategy
where they both happy with what they
doing and there are a couple of them in
this game
can do both a certainly that makes them
happy or they can do both be or maybe
more disturbingly they can run what's
called mixed strategies they're choosing
flipping a coin in the beginning with
probability 5050 of the two strategies
and that's a Nash equilibrium also
picking on dick for some reason if he is
playing a 50-50 mixing then you know I
could also play a 50-50 mixing so indeed
50 field we think is as good as it gets
given that the opponent's mixing this is
not as good an equilibrium from our
social welfare point of view or any
players point of view because up
probably the fifty percent they miss
coordinating but yet it's a Nash
equilibria so these are the three Nash
equilibrium of this game another game
equally well known and famous sometimes
only has mixed equilibria and that would
be matching pennies here there are two
players the game player would like to
match their choosing between heads and
tails the green player would like to
match the red player would like to
mismatch and the payoffs are one if the
right thing happened n minus 1 if it
didn't and the unique equilibria mere is
a 50-50 mixing this is a game so called
zero-sum game the opposite interest if I
then my opponent loses those games will
play a special role in what's coming ok
so these are my two simple games now by
learning and what do I mean by learning
so the classical solution concept of
classical outcome in games has been Nash
equilibria and I guess you know the
famous theorem here is that Nash
equilibria does exist as we have seen
just a second ago sometimes it has to be
mixed strategy that is randomized
strategies but it does exist it's
guaranteed to exist this is not what
Nash proved the question that originated
that the originals of thinking about
learning in game was motivated by is how
do the players not to find it
Kaz raychem affairs find the Nash
equilibrium and there are many reasons
this is questionable or this is an issue
so if I go back to the classical reasons
then things like remember the
coordination game it had three Nash
equilibria so the classical answer to
how they find the players find the
Nashes introspection they sink hard and
then they know to coordinate on Nash but
no matter how hard I saw how did I know
to think of the same mesh as my opponent
that's a low problematic there is also
other reasons that is equally
problematic especially large games the
players are always fully know who they
playing against and what exactly the
game is and how are you going to find
the Nash when you don't actually know
what the game is you introspection needs
full knowledge of everything that seems
somewhat problematic to and then because
we're computer scientist we also putter
that it might be computationally hard to
find the Nash equilibria man indeed on a
desk Iraqis Goldberg and and
papadimitriou proved that it's PPID hi
this is was the first of these results
there is a sequence of other hardness
results that even when an ash is unique
even when otherwise life is good finding
it this computation we had and yet
another convincing reason they won't be
able to find it so the first way that
people started to think about learning
in games it's a way to try to find the
Nash maybe learning is a is a way to
find the Nash so what do I mean by
learning so remember this all about it
as a repeated game so here is a game you
play over and over again I'm going to
you know this a is the action that a
particular player can take so AI is
action of player I and this is happening
period one and then Perry 02 and they
play over and over again and I'm going
to assume that the babies think about it
same the exact same game is played at
every period that gets exact same
opponents
people are looking for good average
performance or they just learn learning
to play this game and the idea is that
in the beginning they don't know what's
going on but if they played enough
hopefully learning they'll have them and
they figure out what is the right thing
to do so that's what we're trying
tomorrow so again the first motivation
for this is a way to find the
equilibrium and this was suggested or
introduced by Robinson in 1951 who also
introduced the one particular method of
doing this or trying to do this cause
fictitious play when the word fictitious
play actually is a different view of a
repeated game there is no in Robinson's
mind or his motivation there wasn't
actually anything getting repeated it's
a sort of pre play or chip talk on
Richard learning how to do this before
the real game happens so when an
important game happens such as say
spectrum auction is an important big
state game there indeed sort of pre runs
in which people can train to learn the
game and they said of this this this
this whole picture I showed you here and
not the real game this is the pre play
in which they learning how to do this
and so the whole ball of this is just
learning that's why the name fictitious
play and here is what fictitious break
concretely suggest you do is pretend in
your mind or believe for a second that
your opponent already knows how to play
and it's doing a randomized strategy and
what you're getting is samples from his
randomized strategy so given that if you
believe were to be correct and you were
indeed doing samples from this
randomized strategy then it would be
rational to best respond to you know the
observed statistical behavior of the
opponent and that's what fictitious pay
is so fictitious play best response to
the past history of the other player so
assumes that the statistically ought to
be half and he played what strategy is
is the distribution and you just best
respond to that and you think of this as
a free play as a way to learn to learn
the game now what does Robbins are
hoping for Robinson was hoping for that
this leads to Nash equilibrium and I
will think about a little bit of what
does it mean to lead to Nash equilibrium
so mom made could leave things to could
lead to Nash equilibrium is this so for
a while they do something I don't know
and after a while they found a Nash
equilibrium and they repeat it over and
over again if this happens it surely led
to nash equilibrium if you see this
pattern in a fictitious play that is if
ever the case that a certain vector of
behavior repeats over and over again
that clearly is nash equilibria game
Isaac Nash equilibria not because
everyone it is repeatedly thinks that
he's best responding the statistical
observation of the other players in fact
it is that what's called a pure strategy
or desert deterministic Nash equilibrium
after a while the whole history doesn't
matter and only thing that matters is
that last thing that they've been doing
over and over again and that's being
stable here so that's a Nash equilibrium
so here is a notation I'm going to use
for this it's a Nash equilibrium i'm
going to say you I or utility of player
I is the value or pay off the player
gasps from this utility this action I a
here is the thing they are repeating in
green and this is the player eyes payoff
or utility from this action here is what
would be player as utility for not
playing the section but they start
playing this alternate action X and if
it's a Nash equilibrium or it is a Nash
equilibrium if his utility is better
than any other action he koto and that
ought to be the case here because if it
wasn't then after a while he would
switch to X or something else so let's
see just explanation of the notation and
I'm going to refer to this as the no
regrets style assumption no regret
meaning
player a I does not regret not playing
strategy access that he's feeling good
about it is not regretting strategy x
okay so let me quickly try this a tonic
on my to promise simple games so if you
do matching pennies and for some reason
to make life is interesting or simple
for me I started some one of the players
up with a history that longer than
non-existence of summer the second
player that remember the one that
doesn't want to match stats vez
believing that he has seen the opponent
played tails twice in a row I'm not sure
why starting from this history what they
going to do is I wrote down here in this
line the history they currently observe
so these players not seen one had zero
tails and then this person sees one had
two tails and what they respond to it
and what will happen in the sequence of
place it's going to take on a cycle
around in a simple for cycle that is
they started at playing head hurts they
apparently in this they will do this
twice and then you're going to switch to
playing this corner to the spice then we
playing this corner do this twice and me
playing this corner did this twice and
so on forever can you just try that this
is what fictitious play does so one
funny thing about fictitious play that's
the deterministic play if the opponent
played our hats 18 times and pay out 17
times 18 is bigger than 17 and you're
going to be convinced to respond to the
heads because there was one more
frequently and no matter how big 18 and
17 is you keep doing this that's what
fictitious places and what they're going
to do is the terminus recycle around so
what we use about this that the
distribution of half and they preach
play each of the corner each of this
grace here is actually the Nash
equilibrium remember Nash was that they
play 5050 the two strategies which means
they land in the squares one folder of
the time and that's exactly what we did
the bad news is that kind of cycled
around we didn't do a random
distribution we do the cycling but the
statistic
so right which is kind of interesting
second which is a bit more disturbing
here fictitious play on the coordination
game here I actually added a little plus
instead of the month to make the players
favor one or the other in case the
neutral to make it deterministic and
let's get them start with a a B remember
this coordination game they just wanted
to do the same thing but if they
unfortunately miss coordinate in the
beginning something really horrendous
happens in fictitious play they miss
coordinate forever from been on after
they miss coordinate advance they both
want to switch and then he goes punk to
switch back and then he goes won't
switch and so on forever and ever never
they never coordinate is there a good
news here I'm not so sure weirdly enough
this also converges like a plate in I
don't know if it converged and certainly
nothing very good payoff is horrendous
but these distributions converged they
converging to 5050 like they play one
you know 18 times the other one 17 times
they converging to a 50-50 distribution
of the two playoffs and as it turns out
whenever a two-person game converges in
this sense the distribution of play
convergence then that's a Nash
equilibrium buts more disturbing they're
not playing that Nash because yes yes
they doing 5050 but they do so in a
coordinated way in a coordinated way
that's horrendous because it has really
bad payoff even a mixed Nash which is
what they converge to has a payoff of a
you know half each any stuff and here
they getting 0 but it is the Nash
equilibria so more generally does this
fictitious Bill it to finding a Nash
equilibrium usually not but there are a
couple of serums that says that
sometimes it does one of which I just
showed you an example of being this one
two-person zero-sum actually in a very
both of them are what I should use an
example for both of them two-person
zero-sum games general
and any generate two by two game the two
person to strategy each game they do
converge but only in this really weak
sense like you've seen a two-person game
it converged to the right thing that
it's a Nash equilibrium but they're not
getting the right payoff they just
statistically converge to it and why'd
it like so it converges in some sense
but it's a pretty weak sense so maybe
this isn't the right notion of learning
and I'm going to suggest that it isn't
and I can I will do this sort of twice
there are two different alternatives
which if you parameterize the right they
turn out to be the exact same thing
which are more convincing versions of
learning at least have nicer
consequences so one version of sorry one
version of more convincing is what was
wrong with this alternation of always
miss coordinating is they played
deterministically if they get convince
between 101 or 102 they 602 is a little
bit bigger let's come let's do that I
don't know if humans do this but that
cause miss coordination so there is most
fixed smooth fictitious red play which
is trying to smooth this out let's not
be so pushy about it so here is one day
to think about this when we then we
thought fictitious play using our
notation we were looking for the strip
to play an exit strategy X strategy X
that maximizes that's the best strategy
with hindsight that is given that the
past actions were strippers or something
and statistics came from I take the
action that would have been best in the
past kid they take the strategy ask that
if I look at what they up I would have
gotten given what the opponent's played
this would be the best strategy and this
is a deterministic rule that
deterministically chooses the best
strategy well assuming Alistair thighs
so here is a smooth version first of all
I'm looking for a probability
distribution i would like to randomize
and instead of maximizing a strategy i
would want to
maximize among probability distributions
my expected payoff okay I cheated this
didn't help at all if you're maximizing
the expected payoff is a strategy
distribution well it's going to pick a
point mass distribution that fix the
best strategy with hindsight this is a
nap at all it's still the terminus to be
picking the single best strategy
designed site but this way of writing it
one can help easily by adding a little
term here let's please randomized
whenever possible so one way to do this
to add a low penalty function err and
editing function or not penalty helping
function with the entropy then mutual
please also push up the entropy so any
little new at least will make you
randomize against equally good events
but if the new isn't is literally zero
then even similarly good event you
trading off entropy against how good the
responses so you having a little penalty
for a low editor for entropy you like to
have a high entropy whenever possible
whenever it doesn't take with a big
penalty of the utility so this for
example when you have seen you know a 99
copies of one behavior and 100 copies of
the other behavior that is the two
behaviors are barely distinguishable for
you then you go and do relatively evenly
evenly randomized because you're going
to want to push up the entropy the
payoff is not so different um here's
another take that is different or looks
different and was actually motivated
from a different action actually if I go
back to the econ communities motivation
then they like to think of this as
reinforcement learning and reinforcement
learning goes who said that let's
randomized because randomization is sort
of a smoother sink so if I have a whole
bunch of things that happen in the past
I'm just think of myself as an
experimenting person that's learning
this strategy works and sometimes it
works and sometimes that works and here
is something I could do I'm going to
mean
in a weight function of you know how
much I like strategies then choose
strategies probabilistic this
probability is proportional to this
weight so higher rate means higher
probability and then do a reinforcement
or an update function that reinforces
things that were good in the past so
here is one particular reinforcement
function which goes under the name of
multiplicative 8 update or hedge and
originally due to frighten Shapira where
you take a above one piece of an
exponential function and multiply it
with how good the strategy would have
been in the last period okay so if you
want to unravel this then this w axe has
a bunch of these terms already in it so
what really is is offer to the some of
your experience is what you getting as
your as your way and you maintaining
these vids that's exactly what we hoped
it does then utility for a section is
really good you push up the probability
utilities bad I don't actually push down
the probability but implicitly I do
because of the normalization term so i
push it up less and therefore at the end
normalized i push it up more two
theorems about these two learning a
method first of all and may be very
beautifully these two algorithms are the
same okay so i had to agree to call them
two and two prime one of them was
motivated by this reinforcement action
that i'm experimenting and i like to do
more the things that worked well in the
past and the other one was a smooth
version of fictitious play you know when
you know when i'm indifferent let's
randomized a bit and it turns out that
with the particular version I I showed
you these two are actually the exact
same thing not not hard to show and
second that they both of them offer you
a formal form of no regret guarantee and
that's why I really like them in
addition to being the same which is
already nice so what do I mean by an
orange-red guarantee but the guarantee
is that for any fixed action
an axe is hindsight if i look at how
much utility displayer i got out of this
is the utility got over time and this
down here is utility you would have
gotten healthy plate X all the time this
is how much it would besides I'd like to
have play tax it's reasonable to pour
that term that I have to plant in here
to make it true regret that's how much
is regretting X and remember we were
hoping for no regrets that was the Nash
equilibrium standard but these
algorithms guarantee is relatively small
regret and what I mean here is that if
you pray for a period of time p and say
the payoffs are between 0 and 1 you can
have as much regret as tu maybe that's
what happened in the coordination game
the good outcome was Valuev on each time
p over a time period of tea and when
they play they got value 0 so they
regretting it very very badly as much as
p but what is algorithms guarantee is
that they were that the regret us goes
less fast than them t and in particular
at the root theory Tommy so that's a
really nice regret star property and
from however many minutes I have left
I'm going to think of this no regrets
playing as a as an outcome some point to
think of what happens if everyone plays
no regret learning yep nope this no
regret guarantee is for an individual
player independent of what everyone else
is doing I guarantee this for myself no
matter what the rest of you are doing I
feel in a second make the assumption
that everyone is doing this but I will
not make the assumption that they using
the same parameters in fact I won't use
the assumption that they using this
algorithm and I want to point out in
about one second that there are many
other algorithms that achieves this not
just these two that are actually the
same algorithm in different disguise so
I want to use and I will spend at a
minute a side or two on this I've only
used no regret as a behavioral
assumption i do want to assume that
people do something that have no regret
i do not mean to assume that they use
this algorithm they can do whatever they
please as long as it has no regret and
in fact there are many options of what
they could do there are many other
algorithms I also don't necessarily one
assume that the true T is the amount of
regret they're getting as long as a
little little off day that they go and
thick it doesn't grow as fat linearly
with dinosaur Kansas okay so what
happens if you do not regret learning
and maybe I was low optimistic of how
far i can get so i need to skip some of
the slides you get to a distribution
which i'm going to or heart in mask well
following hot muscular i think of as
correlated equilibrium and i'll show you
in a second but why do I mean that it
has this no regret property which is
exactly what are learning guaranteed we
had a little bit of regret but if i take
the limit as time goes to infinity then
there's no regret they correlated they
correlate on the x history they're not
at class not an independent play and
this I best can show you in a different
game this is maybe also equally value on
its rock paper scissor game hopefully
recognized rock paper scissor and here
is the cycle that rock beats scissors
scissors beats paper and paper beats
Rock it's also a zero-sum game the
following version of it suggested by
sharply is a little contorted rock paper
scissor payoffs are over there same as
rock paper scissors except if you
accidentally match I minus nine each
it's not a zero-sum game anymore so if
you actually accidentally match than
zero pea but then it's negative for both
of us the Nash equilibrium of this game
is the same but what happens in the
learning dynamic and I want to actually
be generous and start out the learning
dynamic on both players they playing
Nash you just imagine both players are
playing Nash but randomization is tricky
as we all know so maybe that player will
play that strategy it just a bit more
often you place paper a bit more often
now these guys learning algorithm we
will discover the hated opponent playing
paper all the time or too much the best
response to that it's better to play
scissor indeed he's going to place this
or more often and then as a result this
other guy will say oh I see is playing
since it all the time a better switch to
rock because their bits it and so on in
the dynamic will be this sort of
spiraling at and what they really going
to do at the end is some spiraling
around the six squares over there so it
will be very similar to fictitious pray
not very surprisingly because this is
really a variation on fictitious play
but every learning algorithms will do
this whether you doofus pieces play or
not it avoids the diagonal which is nice
in the minus ninth it does some sort of
cycling and it definitely correlates
it's not independently okay so this is
this is what I call correlated
equilibrium so correlated equilibrium is
a distribution of a place that can you
can correlate with you
but you should have no regret expected
payoff is better than I selected pair
for any fixed strategy his hand side
this is exactly what learning converges
to whatever learning they do if it
happens to be independent player then
it's nash equilibrium it's a
generalization of Nash equilibrium
beside this Friday Shapira proved a
stronger version of the zero sum sum
game that we have seen already we have
seen from mere shava that in zero-sum
games even fictitious play converges but
if converged in a very disturbing way
these are generating the right payoff
here we get the right payoff but we do
get the correlative history even if I go
back and have zeros on the diagonal as
it was on on rock paper scissored I
still get the same sick cycle that
people are cycling event okay so I don't
have so much time so I definitely want
to talk a little bit about the outcomes
and actually the switch to one slide off
I want to think of this as earlier as a
model of learning behavior so originally
as I said learning came as a as a model
of finding Nash equilibrium from my
personal perspective this but not so
successful most games it doesn't do that
and given the calmness research that's
not very surprising but then more
recently and more in the 90s it's sort
of emerged that maybe it's a good mole
of the cover of human behavior or
behavior and they're a bunch of these
papers I picked some of its very some
different came from the earlier this era
of ross who's doing a two-person
coordination game experiments and they
wondering which of the learning models
matches better how people behave but
they're thinking it's one of those
learning mode then i actually started to
was very impressed or like this
friedenberg perkovic paper from ec 14
where they actually explaining how lab
experiments honest more complicated
seller and buyer game are very very well
matched with a version of learn
is a bit of recency bias value more
heavily more heavily camel recent
experiments more than past experience
and then more recently in the current EC
denis nikiforov Vasilisa kinase and i
have looked at being adduction data and
trying to match that to learning
behavior this is a more even more
complicated data set another lab
experiment with actual data from
auctions so let me actually spend the
last few minutes on on quality of
learning outcomes and here is I have to
step I would like to step back and think
about congestion games because those are
maybe the simplest wear something nice
can be sad so again think of congestion
game as a you drive into work and you
drive into work every morning and every
morning experience some traffic and
might experience or change your pass
when I think of congestion games this is
maybe a quick picture of what i mean by
mo every Edge has a congestion function
so this congestion acts it has this x
over 100 or some other function of x is
to delay on the edge so in this
particular very simple network with a
hundred participants splitting 50-50 is
the optimal solution but that's not a
Nash equilibrium because there is this
alternate pass here that has x over 100
it's a half plus 0 plus a half it's
faster than the other pass and the
unique Nash equilibrium is that everyone
follows this alternate pass the trouble
is they are following this code is very
congested edges and at all times on top
and this is an example that have
certainly team and I and many others
have used a lot called brace paradox and
one of the papers that that dick
referred to is this paper with Tim that
showed something about quality of Nash
equilibria and this is one way to phrase
it and in this particular setting and I
want page back to it the the Nash
equilibria is not optimal it's better
then a century design optimal solution
that carries twice as much traffic it's
a sort of price of energy statement it
compares the Nash equilibrium to one
solution to an optimal solution to a
solution this bit more traffic and that
it was motivated by what usually
determines the price of energy the worst
cost of Nash equilibrium compared to a
social optimal so if I want to think
about learning I have to take this sorry
price of energy expression and put in
something about average behavior in
learning and that has been suggested by
a paper of Ephraim Blauman momentum
Katrina and error and here is the
natural expression we have a socially
optimal solution which is one thing and
then our average performance remember i
saw that average performance is what I
average behavior average cost every what
I wanted to evaluate that you must think
about if they hopes i switch to cost
because the congestion game is a cost
game average cost over a period of time
T divided by the social optimum and I
take the limit as time goes to infinity
and that's the of referred to sometimes
at the top price of tall energy because
they learn her other than finding Nash
equilibrium so in rotting gave these
many players I guess and in fact in many
many other games one thing that happened
over the many years and I won't have as
much time as I hoped I would to tell you
about this is too we may be studied by
this offering paper and then in a large
way generalizing and and act on
formalized by tim roth gardens paper
with me realize that many many if not
almost all the results we have for price
of energy extend to learning outcomes
that is if people are learners that's as
good an assumption as
found a Nash equilibrium now in trying
to optimize for a few minutes I have
left let me try to extract for you in a
way what's the insight that causes this
to be true without going into any of the
details so here is roughly what the
proof technique looks like you take the
optimal solution remember it's a
repeated game same players same
environment so there is an optimal
solution and you tell them what is the
optimal thing that they should do what
is this a star the thing that the past
they should drive on or something the
route they should take what's the
optimal thing they should drive on and
then here is what no regret gives us
they're not regretting not having done
that in fact it's good to point that
they not regretting anything they don't
have to know about the optimum is in
order to not regret it no regret
guarantee is that they not regretting
anything in particular you're not
regretting the optimum having not known
the optimum this is the morning equality
we kept me have been learning we have
well they not reacting others insider
but those I have to use in the proof
this is the one that seems very very
helpful they're not regretting what we
think they should have done and what
this framework really offers is a maid
to capitalize on this and this is the
technical details i'm going to not sleep
under the rug that this in many many
games and i'll show you quickly a list
of what those games are if you have this
no regret property that is you're not
regretting what you should have done in
the optimum that's good enough to prove
that the solution is close to up close
to the optimal solution so examples of
this is tim framed closely smooth nice
framework and things have improved low
price of energy in the smoothness
framework include lots and lots of
congestion games so not just the one I
had a first but different course classes
of function lots and lots of auction
games you can sell an item separately
first by second price all kinds of other
ways and even some other games down here
that are not either so lots and lots of
games
that have good price of energy they
usually have it for this reason and you
all you need is people not to regret
what they should have done in the
optimum and your home and the proof was
actually so sure they fit on the slide
even though I didn't go through it so I
guess well think I definitely one do is
give you a single example of how you
prove such a band because I didn't even
show you what the band was but instead
spend the last one or two minutes on a
different advantage of learning which I
which we have been recently engaged in
so one thing I said in the beginning and
it's something to say and I said that
you might want to keep in mind till the
end is that learning has many other
advantages one of which it's can adjust
to a changing environment but then when
i try to do any balance i didn't do this
so here is a game repeated game
repeatedly same set of people here and
what we had is the stability assumption
that's currently mostly in the meteor is
a stable in the sense that these players
here and the incentives are completely
stable and fixed and even though i
didn't go through the proofs i told you
why that was namely i need to know that
there is a single optimal strategy a
star and i need to use the fact that
they don't regret this k if i have
different people here in every stuff
then there wouldn't be a single optimal
strategy and maybe then it would be you
know i like we needed that we needed
that there's a single optimal strategy
that they're trimming off so i guess i'm
claiming that learning can adapt to a
changing environment and learners are
better than this and i guess in not oops
actually it might come back to this but
what I one who at least tell you a teeny
bit a bath is a very recent paper by
vasily sir canis and toad or a slick
Aristo taurus is here someplace over
there and mostly will be here in a week
Russell is that Microsoft to Doris's is
a Cornell in both of them were corner
students very trying we extend this to a
more general class of games where you
can change the population our particular
model assumes that the players might
leave so one way the population can
change and that's actually a second okay
model for traffic ratting games is that
the origin destination pairs of people
sometimes change you know maybe this guy
moved away and some other guy moved in
the neighborhood and that guy drive
someplace else so in particular among
layers is that every player with some
probability P leaves and I replaced
wherever's kiss other player so this is
a mix between a slow change because
people are leaving with small
probability so the traffic today is
probably pretty similar it's a traffic
yesterday but in a very worst kinship
because the players the arriving players
are completely worst-case an arbitrary
and in fact the examples I slept through
is one may be a simple example to show
that in this kind of risky shift you
clearly have to try to adjust like here
is a player maybe is around on those red
periods he then he showed up this was
the panic pattern he found a good pass
to drive but as my poster on sand those
people variation some other guys show up
and what I need from a learner if you
make up to this fact please wake up to
this fact and start driving up there I'm
going to actually skip the little bit of
technical details that still ver on my
slides do not run over too much but I
guess it's a high level summary I have
to assume that I have to make an even
stronger behavioral assumption that
so-called people are adaptive learners
that they came capable of doing this
like regular no regret learning there
are plenty adaptive learning algorithms
in the literature so if you want to be
an adaptive learner it's easy to do so
there are many in the literature that
helps you do that they're very simple
very similar to the algorithms that are
regular no regrets learnings basically
let's p recency bias what's wrong here
is the past experiences that top road
congested is not relevant anymore so
let's be a little recency bias is your
learning and that should help and as a
result we have some theorems here that
I'm going to skip and maybe go to the
oops mistake how do we go back I want to
spend a minute on sort of telling you
what I hope you got pic took away from
my talk so I want to think of learning
in games as a good model of behavior I
was happy to recommend it as a model of
this kind of behavior if u verse someone
who wants my advice of how you should
playing games sure if you have a lot of
knowledge it's good to start with
thinking through what might be good in
the game but in games are to repeat it
learning behavior has offers all kinds
of advantages it's a good way to adjust
to changing environment um you do not
need to know about the game is or
exactly who you playing against and
maybe this last point is something I
didn't emphasize in the beginning if it
turns out your opponent's not very good
at this you can take advantage of him
this is in case of opposite interest
like if you play Nash equilibrium it
doesn't matter whether your opponent's
any good you're getting the Nash
equilibria but if your opponent plays
badly shouldn't I be more and learning
does that if you opponent place badly
and go in even more because learning
helps me even more and then the time or
told you about or more MORE I guess so I
didn't tell you as much as I hope that I
more think about is that learning
players do well in in games that is it
it is it inherits most of the price of
energy that and it even
so in dynamic environments that is it
learning can adjust to changing
environments and the play will guarantee
not every time period but overall on
average high social welfare if everyone
or in fact most players are adaptive
learners and I'm going to stop you
Oh
um yeah so I guess starting to see
what's easiest for me is my own paper I
hope in a new version it this is a
working progress of we're looking at big
big data where previous analysis of pink
of this sort of adduction data was
assuming that the place at nash
equilibrium one trickiness in
advertising data that you don't actually
know what people's values I because they
don't tell us so you have to infer they
values and that is usually based on the
assumption that it's nash equilibrium
there are two things I can tell you
about the data and I don't have pictures
to show on like I do but not on this
slide if you look at what the time
series of how people are bidding in that
data it does very much looks like
variation on fictitious play they going
up for a while and then down for a while
it's more like a gradient descent of
some sort they optimizing some objective
function by pushing it a bit in a
direction most people's behavior looks
like that some people are stable other
people go up and down and trying to
adjust sort of the way fictitious play
would going a little bit in some
direction or org Aegean descent maybe
that's a better way to put it second we
definitely know that they have regret
this I know for sure I don't know they
value but I know that there's no value
under which they don't have regret I
know that therefore they have regret I
don't know how much that depends on how
what they value really was but I know
for sure they have regret because there
is no single value under which they
wouldn't have regret so certainly says
that Nash equilibrium is not a good
assumption they're not at nash whether
this particular learning behavior is a
good assumption i'm not sure looking at
the other papers are actually the first
one the like I'm trying to page right
there that i coded is a
it is they trying to trade off which of
the learning whether fictitious play or
reinforcement learning is a better model
of behavior so one interesting question
there is that I don't know if we humans
like randomizing we probably do not so
both of these algorithms are doing
randomization and we agreed that that
pure fictitious play which is
deterministic is not a good model I
don't think to flip over the alternate
miss coordinating 18 billion times in a
row that's not very likely so I don't
know quite hard to like her to the way
they want to do business they instead of
running a one person against another
person repeated play tho those
experiments did we provide it to person
play in a large population so say in a
room I don't know if it's as big as this
but say certain i randomly paired them
or maybe even more fifth as many as say
you guys randomly paired them and
repeatedly pay now from your perspective
you're learning maybe learning and
you're doing repeated him but you're not
playing against the same opponent in
that set up it seemed like every model
of learning matches the data better than
then a Nash equilibrium assumption and
that the most of the paper is about
whether this model is better than that
mole and certainly it's unclear these
different models have different number
of free parameters and I don't know if
they did a proper a be testing to figure
out if what they doing and matching the
data is is simply a fact of how much you
can fit the data or whether or what
exactly happens if you if I go to the
third paper i listed which is a drew
friedenberg paper his main point one and
they're definitely it's a from a seller
buyer game perspective it's a very
simple game the proper your offer a
take-it-or-leave-it price to a buyer
and another buyer offers a
take-it-or-leave-it price to a seller in
the game if you figure out the Nash
equilibrium it's supposed to offer a
price of three and in the game they
repeat it often enough and it's not
going to come out as a price of three
it's really a one-person game the second
person is an automat in that particular
thing there's one experimental subject
and they're this the the recency bias
learning is a very good model of what
the project they should be three and
they coming to five and seems like five
is d the reasons if the focus of that
paper is more the recency bias if I do
learning in that model these are the
recency bias they should have learned
that three is the opportu bit but they
recency bias and as a result they
getting the wrong
it could happen in games and so actually
yeah it's a great point so I the
critical eye cloning as a model and I'd
like it even more if I don't name which
learning method they use and make it as
an assumption on the outcome of your
behavior without naming the assumption
on your behavior itself and I guess one
thing I'm trying to retry it or I'm
thinking about is that may be fictitious
pay is fine actually our variants and
deterministic fictitious play as long as
the environments random enough that's
good enough there but if I actually make
the even stronger assumption that my
name the algorithm is what they do so
smooth fictitious play fictitious play
then these algorithms lead into this
cycles that I actually showed you of
what they do and then it doesn't take so
much cleverness to figure out that there
is the cycle and you could take
advantage of the cycle it can beat me
because you know I'm doing this psycho
sing and that's usually a criticism as a
as a behavioral model of of learning
that you know you would do this good
point here is at the defense of what
camp came at the end so the good
behavior but you're offering me that
some players do even better than no
regret it's possible to have negative
regret miss no regret is a single
strategy behind side if I'm cycling and
you want to beat me you should cycle
with me in the opposite way you should
not play a fixed strategy then you'll
give you negative regret and you could
do that sure as long as you at least
have no regret with a single strategy
with hindsight they were for guaranty
stay
so I don't need people to be done if
they're smarter sure whatever they will
get negative regret because they do a
smarter things then but I assumed they
do that doesn't change the developer
guarantee space however and maybe that's
a good point to make it's not safe to
play an original strategy because of
this like the welfare is safe my r FR
serum is or our welfare serums are
serums if everyone has no regrets some
people are even sputtered they have very
negative regret welfare state but it
might not be good for the player because
you can ship the rougher towards you
against me because I was dumb enough and
play the sink a simple algorithm and you
get you doing something smarter does
that make sense